holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know new brunswick new jersey august
25th tomatoes timonium maryland
magoobies august 26th couple of crabs
and we're going to tejas baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd we'll be in houston
texas september 23rd through the 25th
austin texas for the moon tower comedy
festival and i ain't done yet august
26th will be at fort dallas fort worth
texas what then we're bringing it back
to long island baby
in all uh september 30th and then we're
coming home the boys are the chickens
are coming home to roost baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skankfest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they grow up to be classy yeah
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day
we're down here in aunt toddy's basement
yeah she's upstairs uh-huh cough ache
fever sweat she's telling me she's got
the the delta v
but i think she's just junked out not
gonna lie she's more of a spirit kind of
girl too yeah a little bit i feel that
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table
[Laughter]
through the e-brake on that thing it's a
family episode i got my point across
yeah very she's on the abu ghat it's the
junk i ride with me i can't keep her off
this stuff she's going through my sock
drawer at night looking for uh the dildo
i told her top drawer
i keep it on me i keep it in the freezer
i like it cold
like a reese's cup you know what i mean
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table so that means it is a family
episode
we circled the wagons yet again we want
to come together we want to regroup
recharge refocus that's what we do here
he's uh becoming a bit of an
international businessman i gotta go i
gotta go secure more funding this week
to a degree he's off to a business trip
to europe yeah i'm in charge what am i
am i in charge when you're gone
literally no i don't you're not no what
about the gaskets at the house
get me up there fully listen
uh yeah no you have nothing enjoy the
vacation thank you toby you stopped at
it kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
happy to be here tough break hippie
you drew this george solves i'll call
you when i get down to shore bozo make
sure you're all right send me a pizza or
something what's up gang happy to be
here as always please make sure you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are
iced
[Laughter]
just like foley's dildo
true to the roof there you go and then
patreon.com you sign up there you get a
bunch of [ __ ] i mean like i we might
have the best in the i don't want to say
it a lot i don't want to go toe-to-toe
it's a good time over there you're
getting a lot you're getting a lot of
product we i mean yeah we do uh a bonus
episode of ayg every week we do a bonus
episode of hard feelings every week and
then we do a monthly live stream with uh
with the top tier pages a good [ __ ]
time check that out and also a live show
baby we're on a rogue come hang out with
the boss come see us it's going to be a
good time
right yeah we're having fun we're having
a [ __ ] blast good summer we love you
mixing it up with everybody and we also
love our incredibly talented producer
she's fantastic who's been thinking for
the last 45 seconds how to burn me let's
get to him
he's a recent transplant from the
chicago scene
we got him in a three-way trade with uh
i lost a washing machine in this thing
two dozen chicago dogs we had to give up
uh t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's
up dudes what's up t-bone oh key west
kippy they're gonna hate you in russia
[Laughter]
yeah you can't be wearing those [ __ ]
shirts over there this is where they're
from
what europe yeah hawaiian shirts are
from europe this is hawaiian what is it
grease
[Laughter]
you're going to get kidnapped that's
what do you mean i think you work for
the company i'll go over there [ __ ]
running your mouth
i got big big sunglasses on this shirt
and a briefcase
me and foley just came from a weekend
away
yes a nice weekend where we got along
like [ __ ] chums the whole time we had
a really good time out there at the
wedding of the stars yeah robbie uh
balsam no cocaine i'm a pretty good guy
i don't think there was i didn't see it
no nothing like that going yeah no it
was nice it was a good time it was nice
two guys in nice suits dressed well well
tell me be honest okay yeah for the
listener we we added a social event to
it which we've talked about the yeah
we've discussed it the first of its kind
for us to go as
a mature adult yes as somebody with a
little bit of cash this wasn't an open
microwedding i cannot pay it out no no
this cost a couple of bucks yeah
yeah nice there was grounds yes you were
on the grounds for the weekend you
didn't have to leave nowhere yeah it was
a good time soup to nuts probably
the best wedding i've ever been to
really 100 i mean it was multiple days
yeah it was nice big man in the pool was
pretty good got in the pool i was proud
of myself for that
i didn't i didn't pull any punches on
that i jumped you know took the shirt
right off i said look at world this is
me this is what's going on
and i jumped lifeguard harpooned
[Laughter]
janitor's throwing kitty litter on vomit
[ __ ] trying to spear you with a mop
and i did make sure to stay in the in
until the hot chicks left yeah yeah i
stayed covered yeah and then i put my
here's a fat guy trick for you put your
shirt down at the other end so you when
you gotta get out you get out away from
everybody you throw the shirt on real
quick also
and also you walk with the towel while
you're drying in front of you it would
do that
oh sure i know that move big fan of that
works
but also don't try to say like that's
the gentleman's move that you put your
stuff on the one side and get out that
side no it's not the general
it's it's the fat piece of [ __ ] move but
i mean it's also the only side you could
get out of of that pool oh i
didn't know i was speaking in the royal
sense
i apologize because i i
didn't realize i had a pool engineer
i got to be honest those ladders were a
little wonky even for me yeah and i i
got out first i'm like there's no way
you're getting out this side i had a
tough time getting out of those when i
was a kid that's another reason why i
can't stand uh in-ground pools is
because those ladders in the deep end
not even the last do you ever see that
how about the cow with the kids that
could pull if you had to get out with no
ladder oh
man you're like a walrus coming on the
boat
that's usually where most attacks occur
yeah right there when you're getting out
on the wall
but i want to say you looked very you
looked great you dressed apart you
thought i did at night so you did it you
did it i honestly think you did it as
well as you could do sure you know
i don't know given you're giving your
genetic shortcomings
also
you got a nice blue suit on with a nice
blue floral print but i gotta say that
material if you had to come up with one
word to describe the material of that
shirt what would you call it a space
cause it wasn't cotton space-age oh my
you couldn't like you couldn't set me on
fire if you wanted to do this i'm not it
was it kept somebody said he looked like
a wrestler in high school trying to cut
weight
good because the mate it was like
plastic
it was like
rubber it was vinyl it was walking
around like grandma's couch stain's
fault fell right off i was like having
it's like covering your suit and reinex
yeah it had a very shower curtain vibe
to it yeah the inside one not the cloth
outside of course no yeah no it was nice
well you look good you look good i've
never seen a suit that looked too big
and too small at the same
well the problem time the big guys is
there's a lot out front it's a tough one
that's where you get but you look good
you look pretty good that was the first
time i felt good you were schvitzen oh
oh dude pouring pay every two steps just
jesus christ also there was like four
different locations every time we had a
move he got mad i just cooled down god
damn it hanging over by the [ __ ]
shrimp cost somebody give me some
antifreeze
um yeah i sat right in front of the ac
when we got to when we got to the after
after party
which i usually never make it to sure
and i was telling um
i was telling them that morning at
brunch our good friends robbie and casey
who got married i was telling them this
is the first wedding where i was i
wasn't too embarrassed to go to the
brunch oh been that guy oh my god i i
had to leave a family wedding which i
won't say which one protect the innocent
uh years ago
because i had uh you know i had
extracurricular i had some extra correct
some nose beers yeah were involved and
um i got my hands on that remote in the
hotel room
yeah jacked up a pretty penny on adult
uh cinema and i i bet the room wasn't in
your name the room was not lightning
yeah yeah yeah you're not you're not a
room room in the name kind of guy yeah
well now i am which is crazy that's
another thing too sure now i am i wasn't
a [ __ ] go get your own suit guy
you know what i mean yeah shoes belt
[ __ ] nice nice suits spent a couple
of bucks also did it all myself as nuts
as it is we get there or whatever sunday
and he's going i hope these pants fit
you went up with a pair of pants you
hadn't tried on blind to a wedding
[ __ ] cowboy bro jesus dude talk about
you talking about a guy playing by his
own rules
what were you going to do if they didn't
fit you would have called shorts
fake fake the delta variant
no no no no no towel in the front
fake the stroke at the rehearsal dinner
yeah
but no i had to check out pretty much
like like six in the morning
because there was uh it was about 350
worth of uh
jesus couldn't find your scene could you
big guy
[Laughter]
so it felt good to do that yeah i was in
bed one o'clock every night woke up
early felt good
nice classy yeah yeah nice conversation
was involved a little bit you know you
got a little bit of support
yeah yeah yeah you were a good hang we
had a lot of laughs together me and you
yeah yeah it was good it's good and even
before that we had had we had had a
conversation about something and there
was no fighting there was no that yes
that that would have ruined the weekend
a couple [ __ ] a couple weeks ago yeah
you're maturing it's crazy sure that
nutritionist really did something to me
yeah i could tell by the [ __ ] nine
pancakes she ate yesterday at brunch i
was at a wedding
we're celebrating love hairs you're
lucky we're not weighing in today jesus
christ here we're taking syrups to
go you would not fit into those pants
today [ __ ]
i tell you what it made me want to kind
of get to a point where i could wear a
suit all the time like a presidente
i've never worn a suit just in normal i
don't have the body where you see me in
a suit and you're like oh maybe that guy
works somewhere wears it every day it's
like you see that kind of like oh
somebody died yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean but i felt like i could i
could do
it was nice pancakes were unbelievable
by the way yeah food was fantastic food
food was nice okay before we before we
move any further we gotta get down to
brass tacks sure let's talk envelopes
yeah this is how we're gonna do this so
that neither one of you can lie and
weasel the other one
count of three you both say what you put
in the envelope okay same time so we'll
go three two one go all right so on go
three two one go and then we say yes
okay right three two one go
i did three i did six there's no way you
did six i just wanted to make sure
i wanted to do six yeah
all right hold on in foleyville i did
six oh foley bill i gave him eight grand
and they carried me out on a [ __ ]
yeah on the chair uh-huh also hold on
before i forget there was uh wait how
much did you do three yeah yeah i i went
on record as four three crisp one but
that was a joke that was for comedic
purposes
you said three i said four i mean what
am i going to do i'm shooting the show
here you know what i mean true
uh i did three i mean that's the
gentleman's move plus we were up there
for a while you know what i mean it was
nice
would you leave what'd you leave for the
cleaning that was what i wanted to ask
as well okay 10 piece and i did some
cleaning myself nice i did a 20 piece
because i stole the air freshener
the air conditioner
[Laughter]
i had a little r2d i had one of them
little john's next to my bed well r2d2
john goes out the window not too shabby
not gonna lie oh the the two yeah yeah
yeah it was all right yeah bizarre you
were staying in a shack i was staying in
a tool shed yeah yeah i had a nice piece
of property you had a nice piece of
product i had a wrap-around porch i had
company the first night we were all
hanging out couple of bernies kippy king
correct with a couple of beers yeah
everybody got that no i'm over on the
deck kippy you got a thank you yeah
kippy got a dad i was a talking attacker
i wasn't talking people come up to me
and say do you have a deck i had to be
like no it's kippy yeah i heard you have
an amazing place i'm like nah it's kid
it's like when people talk to me about
the podcast yeah it's really great what
those guys are doing
yeah they're great i also
i also i don't know what it says about
our relationship because people thought
me you and my wife were all staying
together really yeah yeah cannon's like
oh it's fully in here i'm like no
foley's on the phone he's up fully's out
behind the communal bathroom i tell you
what i wouldn't have minded it and and i
gotta say the bird brings an element of
class to the operation she makes us both
look good she does having her connected
to the business
really makes it shine yeah she could
really she has a real wow factor yeah
she what'd she wear to uh the rehearsal
dinner a nice nice pants
and and a nice blazer like it's like a
fashion show very yeah she's a very like
colorful colorful blazer anybody here
i'm with them i am fully because i
follow goes i feel like your teenage son
just just me and my wife taking foley to
the pool
she's handing me goldfish and apple
juice
trying to keep me going it was a good
time but one of the girls one of the
very uh great things was uh
me getting mistaken for the uh yeah
there was a very large drag queen who
sung at the event
right very large voluptuous think about
just like the big busty
you know
big
big bear a little bit of a five o'clock
shadow trying to sit there and enjoy my
[ __ ]
the next morning trying to enjoy my
frittata like a [ __ ] gentleman
just dropped 300 on these kids
[ __ ] suit was five shoes belt forget
it i'm getting insulted on the way out
the door the spacex t-shirt
that's reusable though i save money in
the long run
um
somebody came up to him while he was
sitting there was the mother of the
group i was trying to keep him
i was trying to keep names and faces out
of there oh it was perfect she came up i
was like what what are the exact words
she was talking that she was looking at
canon and she was like him
him he was good like you know she was
doing it then he was good he's like that
was you right the lady guy that was you
i i knew exactly what she was talking
about it wasn't that far off and i
figured you know said that you grew a
full beard overnight come on
but also in in sephora
in her defense you were the only two
people of that magnitude
sure after a couple of times extremely
talented yeah yeah yeah who's who
she could belt out a tune i can tell you
that she brought the house down at the
wedding yeah so yeah i took it and just
played along and then she left and then
the table laughed at my face for what a
good 15 20 minutes it was pretty good it
was a good piece of business yeah what
are you gonna do i was honored
sure sure
um that being said anything else you
want to recap or that's it we had a good
time classy weekend we were classified
a little inside baseball here but most
people know yeah you know casey's ripple
wanted yeah it was good gonna guess on
the show multiple times i got a lot of
dms and comments about the suits about
the dressing up about you know they
wanted to know they seen the pictures
online next time did anybody launch it
what do you mean anybody real embarrass
himself no no that wasn't too bad
no it's kind of kind of a i don't not
reserved but it wasn't the vows were
were beautiful and yeah
nick z comic dj'd
best dj ever he kept it moving it was
fun it was great it was awesome there's
no chico in the morning but still
who's that i don't know isn't that
wasn't that a guy from philly i don't
know man get some confidence in that
will you well you looked at me your head
hell
i laughed something i don't know who the
[ __ ] chico in the morning hey i'm not
giving you chico in the morning i'm
sorry there's got to be something good
behind it if you would have done a
voicemail that was a guy chico from
philly or something like that
whatever that means chico and the man
that was a
cop show in the 70s i think wasn't it
chico and the man yes
yes it was with one freddie prince i
believe oh my god that's right i'm
unleashed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
freddie prince fan freddie prince jr too
there's a lot of voice arc whatever good
kid gonna be uh guys as you know this is
a patreon episode not a patreon episode
this is a family episode we'll be going
over your patreon questions there you go
thank you yes um bozo so fully
discovered wedding cake on the brain
you pulled the questions what do you
have to say
have you ever
what do you got huh you're making fun of
me for one one misstep and a chico joke
you ever park your car not in the
driveway huh
that's something yeah someone messaged
you to that i'm sure because i got the
same message and your bozo's out there
to think your [ __ ] smart message and
both of us the same message we're
talking yeah people people will send me
messages that they've sent to foley and
then they won't they'll change the name
it'll say hey
yeah what up big man i'm like ah they're
for me it works on me i think it's uh
yeah i feel special keep them coming
gang
gangstamps.comstamps.com
stamps.com
we use them we love them we sent out all
the cards with them
absolutely fantastic yeah summer's in
full swing you don't want to be waiting
around in the post office nope use
stamps.com yeah they save businesses
thousands of hours and a whole bunch of
money yeah they get awesome deals on
usps and ups yeah uh it makes shipping
super easy for small businesses uh
without needing to take a trip to the
post office you print official u.s
postage
and shipping fish labels 24 7 without
ever having to leave your desk or buy a
or buy any fancy equipment they send you
everything you need it's easy-peasy you
just need some internet a printer a
computer i don't care if you're in your
car your apartment your house
set it up knock it out it's a no-brainer
saving nearly 1 million small business
owners like you time and money and i
know we got a lot of small business
owners a lot of blue collar guys out
there you know what i mean if you own
jimmy's roofing you got to send some
stuff out stamps.com there you go uh and
with their switch and save feature you
can quickly compare carriers to find the
best rates every single time so stop
wasting your time by going to the post
office go to stamps.com instead there's
no risk and with our promo code garbage
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
no long-term low long-term commitments
or contracts
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the home page type in garbage at
stamps.com promo code garbage stamps.com
never go to the post office again folks
this podcast is brought to you by our
good friends at better help if you got
something going on in your life that
you're trying to get off your chest we
highly recommend better help um
they match you with a licensed
professional therapist and you can see
them from the privacy of your own home
and you could start seeing somebody
within about 48 hours of when you first
get on the website yeah it's available
to everybody worldwide you log in see
message anytime you can send it to your
council you'll get a timely
and thoughtful response plus you can
schedule a weekly phone session or video
session so you never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room with uh like
as you would with traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic mattress matches so
they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed they want you to
start living a better life today uh you
can visit their website and read
testimonials that are posted daily
uh that's better help h-e-l-p join over
the one million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
uh help of experienced professional in
fact so many people have been using
better help that they're currently
looking for
additional counselors in all 50 states
expansion baby
special offer goes for ru garbage
listeners you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com garbage one more
time uh that's betterhelp.com
garbage for ten percent dewey kip
kipperino oh yeah let's talk about that
helix sleep baby
making the most comfy and best
mattresses
anybody ever made the best in the biz
cause you know why why's that cause they
don't just throw out a mattress at you
nope all right what about willy nilly
you take a quiz
you let them know what you like how do
you sleep i sleep on i sleep cold me
personally i sleep fat yeah so i need
the plus size john yep so you go on
there you take the quiz they know what
you're working with
easy peasy
unbelievable yeah they match it uh for
you guys me and my wife we took the quiz
and we were matched with the twilight
model
mattress uh
it's fanta i've never had a mattress
that was tailored for me i was always
just sleeping on whatever i you know was
in the basement or something from
college or whatever this i heard they're
building one for your forehead
they very well could be uh
the forehead model so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress it's matched to you
and the mattress comes right to your
door shift for free you don't ever have
to go to the mattress store again nah
we're in the middle of a global pandemic
if you're going to a mattress store and
sleeping on a mattress you're a bozo
what are we doing helix baby helix is
awesome but you don't take my word for
it they've been voted they've been
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazines what yes what are we doing
just go to helix sleep.com garbage take
the two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you with a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life i'm telling you it's been a game
changer for me since they sent it to me
they have a 10-year warranty and you'll
get to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free and they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but i'm
telling you you will you will helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattresses
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
hillixsleep.com
that's helix sleep.com garbage for up to
200 off and two free pillows now back to
the show um we got some [ __ ] heaters
um talk to me this one uh is from our
boy no famous franco this is uh what uh
you know he introduced something
that i was not expecting endor
this starts off with h-y-o-a-i-y-f
the hell is that have you or anyone in
your family
[Laughter]
that might be on a t-shirt coming out
pretty soon that is a good
piece of business good idea i thought of
a week ago yeah
what is it again h-y-o-a-i-y-f
have you ever have you or anyone in your
family that could be our soda toe
soda or whatever yeah
um
all right let's get into some of these
uh this one's from murdoch and i would
define this as a tough look it says
first time did you ever have to rent a
vcr as a kid
which our school would do that like you
could rent an electronic if you needed
it wait what i thought your school would
go and rent it for class no you could
rent from them no it wasn't like a
[ __ ] blockbuster i think like if you
you could i remember at some point you
could from like
the library the library or something had
it yeah i don't know i mean i wasn't
doing it i just think it was for like
people who couldn't afford it it was
like you could check it out at the
school library so
the kid could enjoy a [ __ ] vhs or a
dvd you could go rent i think it was for
underprivileged families for the weekend
yeah it was probably for like three
dollars a day or something
yeah that's a tough look
i do remember walking in a rental center
once with my parents
really yeah can't remember why
but it wasn't because we were killing it
i know yeah yeah
yeah i remember you weren't looking for
franchising opportunities
it was a more of do you have an
application and what's a sectional cost
i remember walking in there once and
taking a lap around the place and we
weren't just browsing we weren't killing
time they were trying to make a move
what they which they eventually made i
want to say it was an entertainment
center that they wanted i still i got to
be honest with you i don't understand
them what do you mean tv got the [ __ ]
stuff and what do you just make a
payment towards it oh rent a center i
don't know how that works
oh you're explaining entertainment
centers to me yeah
okay
all right wow
jesus christ how stupid do you think i
am
you got the speakers on the side yeah
family pictures in the bottom
i mean i survived through the 90s you
don't think i have you don't think you
don't think big dan had a big wooden
entertainment center with the blankets
in the bottom cupboard come on that's
nice movie stocked up the whole nine we
had a pretty uh pretty shitty one
downstairs that my dad put together
after several coors
he was not happy about it this thing is
tv was sliding brutal
um i think when they around the time
they pulled the trigger on that was when
they were snooping around rennes center
keeping their options open but would run
a center would you just pay like 19
bucks and you get a tv for the month i
don't know the [ __ ] company kippy i
don't know for dirt balls what do you
want from me
i think i was in there [ __ ] looking
over the contract i don't know
oh that's trying to get a decent night's
sleep on one of the couches you know how
you now you know rent-a-center is
garbage how's that when you look at
their pricing it's by week
yeah that's what i'm saying so what's it
a week give me give me some numbers here
all right this this give me a sectional
i'm looking at it right now reclining
sofa in loveseat 34.99 a week
same as cash price 1600
total cost to own 36. wait what's 1600
1600 to buy straight out yeah that's
what doesn't make sense it says same as
cash price 1600 but then it says total
cost to own 36. i think if you go in
there with a [ __ ] stack of ghee they
give it to you for 16. that's your
credit if you want a debit card no it's
going to be 3800 no no no if you want to
do the monthly payments of 36 it's going
to be 100 months i think that's what it
says 104 payments so you do you do rent
to own
but you could give it back i think they
take i think the usual thing is you stop
making payments and they take it back i
remember watching you think they take it
back i know they do because i was
watching a true life about it how are
they gonna get in there and you have to
come with the cops there's no way
renaissance well you don't you don't own
your own house if you're renting
furniture you're running an apartment
you don't know that
no one's buying a house and then renting
for i wouldn't say no one let's say in
this instance you own them i'm all right
i'm talking the vast majority of people
fine so they go they go to the [ __ ]
management office and go this guy owes
us this [ __ ] money and they probably
let him in what yeah
oh man or something are they [ __ ] i
don't know what the i remember watching
like a true life on mtv where they came
and took the guy's couches and i was
like i didn't even know i was like what
in the [ __ ] i thought reynolds center
just sold [ __ ] with shaq or whatever
then he this he was the spokesman i
think he's got his fingers and
everybody's pot yeah big fingers yeah
big fingers um man um that's a tough
look yeah 34 a month 34 a week a week
what the [ __ ] 100 weeks two years two
years you have your [ __ ] what's 30
40. i mean it's there to make them
business thirty-four make that money
sixty eight
sixty-eight uh
hold on just so i understand your math
why are you times in thirty four by
thirty-four
no thirty-four times two
okay it's thirty thirty thirty-four plus
thirty-four is 68 16. it's 140 bucks a
month
but if you but the type of person who
shops at rent-a-center they say 140
bucks a month they're going no way would
you show them 34 bucks a week too bad
too bad i got that 140 bucks a month is
no no way no they ain't got that
no you might have two weeks in you on
that couch
damn they come knocking also i mean yeah
you can't you can't run with a couch you
know what i mean they know where it's at
let's never answer the door sleeping on
my comfy couch i mean
yeah true heck i couldn't hear in this
tempur-pedic sofa
dude okay so repo guys for cars like
they get [ __ ] with heavy i get that
can you imagine having to go into
someone that's what i'm saying there's
no way
how about you look look up
how does renaissance get the furniture
i'm telling you this ain't no [ __ ]
they're not playing patty cake over
there this is [ __ ] renaissance
bruisers
baseball bats with nails
okay he's sleeping these are dirty dirty
people okay they're getting their
[ __ ] recliner back
they definitely smash a window or
something let them know you were here
yeah yeah cut the bird's head off or
something because i would think it'd be
like amazon
they just let you keep the couch there's
no money in there to be giving the
couches away there's no money in amazon
just sending you another one either yeah
but they do
how is there
what if i buy a couch off amazon and i
say oh it didn't make it and they sent
me another whole couch that's what they
do they don't care they say oh i found
the couch they say keep the couch you
got two cats
i have two i got nine couches i have two
200 trash cans in my apartment right
what do you think 200 of them is to who
first of all that's that's what it costs
you 200. yeah what do you think it costs
them
amazon yeah i don't know it's a nice
trash can
[ __ ] 18 bucks think yeah best now
they gotta pay a [ __ ] guy
to receive the [ __ ] to you know
to receive the trashcan that you send
back open it up inspect it
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] so you're telling me
in the future there's no returns i can
just economy of scale i can just get two
of everything no i didn't say it so why
wouldn't i every time i order an amazon
package say hey it didn't get here
because i mean most people are
good honest people
i could do that with toys i can get two
of each yeah there you go lose one in
your belly button and your answer
it's killing over here yeah what do you
got so this is from a a furniture repo
guy who says it's like an ama on reddit
i found and he says well we it's like
how do you uh
how do you repost someone's furniture
he's like well we generally go with if
they open the door and can see the
furniture we come in parentheses not
sure if that's legal yeah but we
technically cannot come in until they
allow us and he said the worst thing you
have ever had to repossess was bunk beds
that had kids and
guys don't rent your [ __ ] furniture
you don't want to put yourself in a
position where some
some ex-con has to come wake up your kid
and steal his [ __ ] race car bed you
got to earn bunk beds yeah even i know
that did you don't see me buying bunk
beds i would love that
you can't do that man i had bunk beds
growing up yeah me and danny had them
yeah they weren't getting uh put on a
tow truck in the middle of the night no
no but
look guys stop renting your [ __ ]
furniture okay
go on facebook marketplace yeah i agree
with foley you have to earn bunk beds
you don't just get [ __ ] bunk beds or bug
bags are a luxury item maybe stop
drinking that five dollar coffee from
starbucks every day save up your yeah
kids are resilient then you know
that they can make do they
when you're a little kid you're not
really sure what's going on
they don't need bunk beds he repossessed
a fridge
yeah yeah of course
how you gonna do with this butter
hey buddy i'm taking a fridge
dude go to a junkyard go to the [ __ ]
facebook marketplace don't be putting
yourself in a position where someone can
come steal your [ __ ] back those children
are either going to become the next jeff
bezos or be on ru garbage in a couple of
years yeah or or become dahmer
you don't there's no there's no straight
up the middle with that when you're a
little kid you remember was [ __ ] the
night that [ __ ]
jimmy came in to [ __ ] take your bed
away yeah you and your brother sitting
there looking at each other like idiots
one time we left uh we left tough luck
we left an apartment complex or like a
town it was apartment i would say
with my dad
left
we moved
under the moonlight and i remember being
like some
i remember being like this ain't right i
was maybe about four or five and i
remember looking around going i don't
think you can take the cable boxes with
you
he's [ __ ] this guy burning everybody
all over the town
it was something was up i don't even
even as i grew up i don't remember where
that apartment complex was i would go i
would drive around looking for it
sometimes as i got a holder big i think
it was back here these kids driving
around looking for their bunk beds i
never found that [ __ ] place
yeah kids remember is what i'm trying to
say shacked up in a mirage i've said
this before but i remember when i
realized
i don't know i remember when i realized
that we
that we weren't wealthy is when on the
ride home from the hospital
when you pulled into the driveway ah
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
this thing's got wheels i gotta sleep in
this [ __ ] all right
hey toots do me a favor drop me off at
the firehouse will you
leave me in a basket i ain't growing up
with you animals
jesus have you ever heard rent to own
god damn my parents had a huge
german shepherd too
the baby god damn patty
that's a bad look i don't know if they
got it [ __ ] to protect me or to keep
me in my room but that [ __ ] way
it worked
it was like hogan's heroes in there i'm
digging tunnels underneath my crib
trying to get out of the place [ __ ]
german shepherd standing there in
attention [ __ ] eyeballing me i think
i told you that right about the beagle
we had rusty
rusty turned on me one day
and we had a he was he didn't like kids
my double agent
[Laughter]
he didn't
he didn't like kids my age tried to do
this thing kevin every time he came over
we had to put him out on the leash every
time i had a friend over we had to put
him out on we had to put the dog out on
the leash or that's about rolling out
the welcome mat yeah
i've done that get to my parents door
and they're holding the dog back like
it's a [ __ ] rodeo bull and i had left
for two weeks on vacation with my dad so
i didn't see the dog and when i came
home i don't know if he forgot about me
he didn't like to smell on me what he
was not a fan so he attacked me at night
i got home like late at night from like
the airport
and uh
i was he was like growling at me my
mom's like oh yeah he'll be fine
whatever i'll just you know let him
sleep on it or something that that ditsy
broad what the [ __ ] so i wake up
as soon as i turned him back on the son
of a [ __ ] i heard a bottle breaking
so he
came at me with a
half broken night train bottle
so i wake up
the next it was it was a salt it was
like an eighth grade summer
[ __ ] hobo dog
those are my beans
thanks for checking in tobes
i didn't so it was the summer so i wake
up
everyone's at school or work or whatever
everyone's at work and it's just me oh
i've been hemmed up like that and the
dog's waiting outside my [ __ ] bedroom
door yeah great so i open it up and
i go well i [ __ ] this is a pre-cell
phone this is pretty everything
so i ended up having a bag of pretzels
in my bedroom shout out to rolled gold
extra thin like a fat kid does
right i threw a couple of them into my
mom's room did you have to break the
plastic that they were in there
i'll break in case of a merch in case
angry dogs outs only break in case angry
dogs outside
is did rusty turn on you yet in case
kremlin pops up on tv break and eat and
watch so i threw them nothing on that no
it's stunk fair enough
court adjourned
you may proceed how much is the
guilt here aren't i please guilty
uh
racking up points on your comedy license
you have to turn it in suspend me for
two weeks uh so i threw the pretzels dog
chased the pretzels i ran out the front
door and had to spend the rest of the
day outside like a [ __ ] jerk off
thank god i had to we had to code to the
fridge so the the garage was fair game
the garage door opener that fridge was
stocked cool yourself that was not
nothing but ice pops and gatorades that
day baby you lost control of your house
to a 12-pound dog yeah the dog took it
for lunch she had a gatorade
he had a gatorade and a frozen piece of
kielbasa
old mahi
um
how did we get here i don't know but
that was a good one uh renting oh my dad
moving they're going home
you being poor oh yeah realizing was
what german shepherd
shout out to shout out to mike rusty
didn't last too long mike got porcupine
in the backyard it was is this your
cousin what are we talking about no you
know my dog might i know i was making a
joke jesus christ sentence don't you say
anything about my doggy sentimental
steve over here even though he tried to
murder me several times as an infant
yeah they caught him one time he called
the kibble they caught him one time he
was carrying me around in his mouth when
i was frightened
no he was no he wasn't shot me in his
bowl
you know it's pretty garbage you guys
might have missed it did you guys have
the dog food when you were a kid that if
you put water in it it would turn to
gravy
that was the big thing when i was a kid
you're just feeding your dog instant
mashed potatoes yeah i don't know what
you're talking about i don't think so
you know you know what i'm talking about
dry dog food uh it might have been
called gravy something
not something but sure gravy bits or
something okay you poured gravy train
what the [ __ ] there it is you don't
remember gravy train dog food
you poured water on it and it turned
into it turned into gravy yeah the dog
would eat it
we were like we were the hard purina and
then every now and then throw some wet
on that
i don't know
i hated those days
that was when my mom was working late oh
dude i used to hate feeding the dog wet
food when i was a kid beefy classic
gravy train yeah they still sell it
they got a rental center i do remember
that package yeah yeah
how about the people who gave their dog
what was it cesar or cesar
that stuff you mean billionaires
or what was the one was they served it
like it was the catholic yeah yeah fancy
feasts fancy feasts yeah it was served
that stuff was too expensive for even us
to eat my mom would have been like no
way
it was served in a champagne glass yeah
it was always it was like a fluffy white
cat yeah i never liked those like a real
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
try to make a move on her
[Laughter]
yeah big cat treats we had we had a cat
my younger brothers had a cat as we got
older and then we gave that thing catnip
one time oh buddy like woodstock
[ __ ] throw on some hell's angels show
up start clearing the house
i got the big man rolling next thing you
know you got a [ __ ] meth lab in a
laundry room oh jesus yeah that catnip
i'm firebomb and yeah it's crazy man i i
didn't know what but he busted the ball
open and got all of it and it was a
[ __ ] wrap
that was christmas day there was
wrapping paper everywhere gotta send him
to betty ford for a couple weeks to dry
out
[Laughter]
thank you for laughing at that toby i'm
laughing i'm laughing you can't you
you can't keep calling me out it makes
me so uncomfortable i appreciate it
thanks for having my back on that
piece of [ __ ]
um
striking out let's see here uh this is
from jimmy mcnulty polish guy i didn't
tell you i knew i knew we were poor
oh yeah i'm sorry
we went sledding one time and we had
cool you had to use cardboard boxes
i think i've mentioned this on the
podcast yeah thanks for [ __ ] bringing
us to a halt to tell something you've
told i don't know
seven or eight all you gotta do is go to
walmart paddy what the [ __ ] ten bucks
you could have gotten something
now i feel sad after i masturbate
holy [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] i was scarred as a child
i can't imagine those kids in the bunk
beds are up too
there's probably one sitting over here
that's probably yeah
oh man
you imagine that
get your friends over one day [ __ ]
hot new bunk beds they come over there
what do you say
well you gotta lie oh yeah we got robbed
yeah or something my dad's in the c.i.a
oh yeah something darth vader took it i
don't know whatever you want yeah but it
ain't ain't got repossessed yeah it's a
tough one tough look
um did you ever eat any of the gravy
train
no i didn't toby
i did i totally did that [ __ ] was
delicious
there was no dog so you're telling me if
i buy gravy trained dog food on amazon
and lie and say it never showed up
they'll send me a second bag of gravy
two bags
you choose
i got two bags of gravy training you
choose oh baby
by the way i got the face-to-face thank
you from paul verzie about my said gift
at the
at the barbecue can i tell a story about
that sure um
shout out to or just a
and a a compliment all around what a
gentleman he is what a wise man he is
too
because the story was told to me by mr
verzi himself
um
was that thank you very much for being
upon me this beautiful catchphrase of
you choose you choose kippy all right
that's me folks for the listener i'm
kippy yep uh gentleman that he is
reached out to a good friend of mr
verzi's a young man by the name of
giannis pappas
all right and asked him hey do you
happen to know what version likes to
drink i'm going out to the house and
don't want to look like a [ __ ] idiot
and he said he sold me out he was with
verzi who's with verzi but mr verzi and
his wisdom
did not tell giannis to say anything
he told giannis to say he doesn't know
because verzi wanted to see
how kippy did
he looked at you and he said
you choose yeah i got thrown down the
you choose gauntlet by mr version he
wanted to see how he did and he told me
he showed up correct yeah yeah yeah very
nice his wife who's a fantastic
unbelievable top-notch
uh she's like he's been telling
everybody about that really yeah he goes
i've been telling people he's been
telling everybody he goes it's been
making its rounds i don't know who that
means
i don't know who that means i know
exactly what i'm bringing him now but he
says it's going in a circle he goes
that's going around in a circle nice i'm
gonna bring him a bottle of louis
what no i'm gonna make sure you're not
invited okay i'm on the intersection how
much is that how much is the bottom
louis trace i don't know what that is
just type it in
it'll come up it's an expensive bottle
of liquor
it's cognac you think he likes cognac
this is gordy
it comes in like a like a steel case
this looks like something that uh how
much is it though
uh i'm looking i'm looking at how much
for a bottle of that it's like
more than you could afford fats how much
oh my god let's play a little game kippy
loves called guest 2500 12 grand
12 now it's 25 well kibby followed it
ruined the fun
3 90. that's what i'm getting them i'll
start saving up now making sure you're
not invited
i'll just show up anyway
leave it on a picnic table run away
mail it to him um
classy
ah this is a [ __ ] home run this is
from lance is it garbage a good of and
as an adult with a black eye
dude if you're working in a cubicle with
a black eye that's [ __ ] tough
holy [ __ ] man what a [ __ ] question
people do they get them somehow i know
not fighting they just get them you're
at the copy machine like fight club yeah
crazy [ __ ] pickup hockey game or
something happened
take an elbow at an intramural
basketball game
that is a you you're off presentations
for a little while yeah you got to lay
low yeah work from home it doesn't take
taking the pto something yeah you can't
be you know standing up pitching [ __ ]
you know the new clients
with it with a black guy and a hickey on
your neck that was one of the the funny
things uh
i visited my buddies in ireland years
when we were in college and come monday
morning when you're taking the bus
everybody just has marks
from the fights they got in that week
not everybody but it's like sure you're
sitting on the bus and there's three
guys with like fat lips and black eyes
you're like oh man they get after it
over here these dudes are [ __ ]
partying oh you know how you know if
you're garbage if you call a black eye a
shiner shiner's tough
shiner's tough and put a stake on it
i didn't do that and that i saw that for
the first time that from dennis leary in
the sand lot i said hey listen i don't
know what kind of health what kind of
[ __ ] health insurance you got but i
think the crazy thing is the only thing
it does is it's cold yeah it's just cold
yeah yeah there's nothing to do with the
enzymes and the meat that's what i
thought no no no it's just steak just
cold just cold he did that a lot back
then uh i think they also uh
they had a lot of stakes it was readily
available and plus it like conforms to
the face stakes are readily available i
think like people had stakes in their
freezer yeah
this thing is like do not do this it can
cause infection it's so bad yeah
yeah you get [ __ ] steak eye
[Laughter]
yeah i meant that as a joke yeah leave
that in hey fat man slip me at 20 i can
make that disappear
i'll be at 40. it stays
um what are you waiting on i thought he
was about to tell us something he just
did he said don't do it oh that was it
oh man i thought there was more to it
something was more of a definition no
that's tough i never only had a black
guy once i got hit with a baseball bat
metal baseball bat as a kid nice yeah so
that learned yeah
um
we got you rusty
i hear you're going on vacation he's
hitting it in his hand
here you got a big oral report tomorrow
huh
pretty boy yeah that was a [ __ ] dude
adult black eye
bad bad
you should probably break the other one
and make it look like you had like you
know rhinoplasty or something or put
makeup on that that only goes so long
did you ever like really dig in on a zit
when you were in high school and then
have to cover it up with makeup and it
looks so bad i just would never
uh even with this now if i get a pimp
you gotta yeah time is of the essence i
can't resist i'd rip into it i know yeah
i never had it it usually goes wrong i
never had it really really bad as a kid
like no i don't know if i
that's why every time i got one i would
destroy it because i seldom got them i'm
lucky with that yeah yeah yeah so like
nothing ever like [ __ ] them up i had
yeah i had some [ __ ] heaters for sure
yeah but i mean i hadn't been tagged on
my face at one time i had impentango
here and i had a ringworm right here
hear that ladies
all american catch over here
this rest [ __ ] dermatologist danny
dr pimple oh
yeah yeah um this is another home run
this is from mike s ever sit in a splash
zone
[Laughter]
wait what's this
i don't know something where you're
gonna get wet and it's probably not at
the classiest establishments i don't
think the [ __ ] king or queen is
sitting in the splash zone is that like
when you go to like the log flume or
whatever it is like great adventure and
you go stand on the on the on the bridge
so you can get splashed when they go by
that or if like at the sea world or some
sort of you know any water event you're
sitting close to get wet is the idea
never been to sea world yeah and i never
would go
ever cause you're never invited
look at the cage either way
yeah that's a [ __ ] homework i told
you a story where they tried to get me
to [ __ ] go and i was yeah that ain't
happening it ain't happening this guy's
a lot of things but he ain't no mark
ain't no john no trick no
gotta get a pretty early in the morning
to screw this guy over and believe me i
tried
it's a shame i don't get up before no no
um 8 30. god damn he's ready
back to bed
that kippy don't miss gets up at the
crack at 11 30. i can't get to him
having fun
um this one is from michelle
which every now and then i hear a
question where i go holy [ __ ] that's
something i hadn't thought about in a
long time right which happens with our
guest like we asked our quest we asked
questions to our guests like holy [ __ ] i
never thought about that this is one
after already thousands of thousands of
questions
did you ever have to duck down in a car
because you didn't have enough seat
belts for everybody
jeez that is a [ __ ] deep cut that
explains most of the 90s for me yeah i
could do one better than that might have
already discussed this my dad drove a uh
company car
my mom drove a company car no one was
allowed in to put us
my mom would drop us off to school every
once in a while
we'd have to duck down we'd have to we'd
have to take the ride from the house to
the swamp down yeah whoo so nobody would
see us yeah we were a big
my stepdad used to have one of those
ford rangers that had those little
[ __ ] jump seats in the back
and there was a lot of time where i had
to hit the deck because i wasn't sitting
and then i was just like sitting in the
back it would be hit the deck or if
there was like multiple people we lapped
it up a lot on the way home from like
soccer practice like pack them in there
yeah because my dad will be like because
you know my brother and all his friends
are all played on the same team or
whatever so my dad was like i'll just
grab all [ __ ] six of them and then
like you weren't getting pulled over for
that in the 90s now and you certainly
weren't getting a ticket for it no you
know seat belts even for us i remember
my mom was like you got to wear your
seat belt at least in the front seat my
dad was like
it was
he would fake put it you know sometimes
they started doing they started doing
the click it or ticket you would get the
checks
and my dad would just pull it down as we
drove by like at some like intersections
or if you're like leaving like a park
short they would have a copy like let me
see your let me see your thing he just
faked it hey you know hey don't get to
see i always knew when he got when he
got seen by a cop on the highway because
real quick he would [ __ ] you know
fake put his seatbelt on in case he was
getting pulled over
real fast and loose i like that
it's nice yeah back of pickups all that
[ __ ] there oh forget it
middle of winter backup pickups
best time of your life
fresh air
horribly
horribly irresponsible yeah i remember
one time there's a big storm like if you
would have gotten into an accident we
would have went flying right like
straight
yeah i mean it would have been like
everybody would have been dead everybody
i mean i don't know how fast we're going
i don't know the schematics of this
accident you've made up in your head but
it ain't good
it ain't ending well i saved 12 people's
lives
in the accident in my head gotcha okay
toby 40 bucks that also stays in
um all right uh
everett this is from patrick uh ever had
a sketch artist do your portrait on the
boardwalk the ones where they over
exaggerate all your features
the fact he didn't know what a character
tour is oh i just [ __ ] it up
a caricature
character that's a tough one for kippy
caricature
and i did and they always had like a
hockey stick or a baseball club or
whatever you know what i mean like what
kind of sports do you play
got a huge hog in your hand
a chugging [ __ ]
no never got those always one of them
yeah patty wasn't throwing down for that
she's she's a great kid we love we love
you best mom best mom ever but those
kind of things weren't going to flop
that was just looking at your mom lady i
can't make him any bigger
i only brought it in half by 11. i don't
know what you want me to do you have to
pay with two sheets of paper
[Laughter]
listen lady i only brought one marker
all right i don't uh
this thing's halfway out of ink already
if i do him i gotta go home for today
um my mom asked him can you make him a
little slimmer
he's
he has less skin tags than that
[Laughter]
ah that was a difference we would i
would get that stuff the 15 the 10 the
20 dollar style hey go
were you an old-timey photo family that
was one of the first original are you
garbage questions i ever i ever asked
old the old-timey photo down
on the boardwalk where you guys black
and white and you're an [ __ ] no no i
never did that oh really i did that an
old girlfriend made me do it yeah it's
always a guy doing it for his girlfriend
or wife or something that it's never fun
it's never like three of the homies
doing it
all [ __ ] in the big suits and [ __ ]
yeah it's a tough look
no i never did that
i'm not a [ __ ] it was me and her mom
and her and they were both dressed like
you know [ __ ]
i mean they they're dressed like 1920s
what are you doing here they were both
on each shoulder it's very confusing
listen i made the wrong move i'm not
gonna sit here and act like i was a
gentleman i thought the old lady was
throwing one on me
hey it was 18 you know what i mean
i don't know what to tell you i'm
sitting there i got a tommy gun i look
good i got the three-piece suit on the
hat the loafers i'm thinking
she got the lingo hey doll face yeah
i'm thinking i stand a chance with this
old bird
fake money went to my head
that plastic cigar
started feeling my tony soprano
plastics are gone
that some other [ __ ] poor schmuck was
just chilling on
ah
good times
oh god this one's good uh that was great
um this one's funny this one's from matt
guzzo ever gotten too drunk to drive
home and left your car at the bar for
more than one night
so you don't have to go pick it back up
for another day or two cause i did that
friday
where oh yeah man i was real social this
weekend and good hanging out not too
drunk how you doing good to see you not
bad huh i'm becoming the foley you
always wanted
well i figured
see three days of being doing normal
person behavior has gone straight to
your head like ricky bobby's dead
yeah that's exactly what you are
there's a rat my cop salad
i knew cops al was going to gay would
you just call me
start picking up toby for no reason
son of a [ __ ] have you ever had a tab
open at a bar for more than a night oh
my god you're talking to [ __ ]
kevin i forgot to pay to bill ryan what
are you kidding me this guy sneaks out
about the back door i've never done it
intentionally i've definitely uh there
was there was two years up here where he
left his credit card or atm card at a
bar
on a weekly basis
which kid was boozing i don't know why
you're taking these personal shots of me
i thought we were having a good time
hanging out
i believe i paid for some of those
drinks you had to hang out yeah right if
memory serves if history serves me
correctly i definitely have bought you a
couple of spritzers from time to time
start attacking my character in a public
forum it's ridiculous
also now i'm dreading foley had three
regular days in reality of now how long
of a stint we have to do in foleyville
at some point oh yeah by the way we now
have an official foleyville alarm
[Music]
what i'm trying
[Laughter]
we don't do drops on the show but that
one's gonna stay oh love a good foley
bill yes all right let's do one or two
more and then we will
scoot on skedaddle wait what was that
last question the character
but the last question was the character
i think so maybe huh yeah i threw a
curveball in there with the open tab
yeah
oh no this was leaving your car at the
bar for more than one night no i left i
listed in the city one night because i
don't want to drive drunk yeah i did it
back when i was living at home
college might have been like the summer
or whatever like just after college uh
got drunk at this place called tony's
out there in ivy land pa shout out to it
shell of a tomato pie is pleasing those
are pretty good they got a nice back
porch everybody's hanging the beers you
got the flyers games i wish tomato pie
was more of the philly thing than cheese
steaks i wish more people where do you
get good tomatoes
oh yeah yeah it's so unknown yeah um but
core police is where you get it that's
the answer to your question that being
shout out to court police that being
said i get all boozed up over the place
i get back what do i say three times
okay yeah okay
one will do one more time i only told
him three ah
where was that shmore police
i uh i got all boozed up at tony's and
left my car and then it was like i
should have went at like
8 a.m to get or whatever i pushed it off
all day and i just left there my cats
whatever
came back there was a classic car show
going on around
the mercury montego like they had it all
sectioned off and it was all classic
cars like a hot rod convention and my
car was in the middle of it
it my mom pulled up she and we were
already kind of fighting because i gotta
drive yeah i just got home for something
you know what i mean she's driving her
[ __ ] 22 year old fat sunday
at the bar at five o'clock the next day
to get his [ __ ] car i'll say that's
when they got to testius is when when
you were when you were post high school
you know yeah supposed to be in college
yeah yeah yeah that's where my mom got
real real short with me yeah dropping me
off the landscape when i was 22. oh man
yeah late for work making i'm making her
late for work in the summer yeah
bitching because she didn't make me at
lunch
like 28.
tough luck man yeah so i j it was like a
[ __ ] scene trying to uh
i mean then i'm like they had to move
cones and stuff for me to get out there
was set up i was it's a good thing you
had that hot whip
it had to be the montego and not the
lumen it had to be the teego tough look
yeah tough i try to make a joke i'm like
yeah it's an oh five or whatever they
weren't the old timers weren't having it
probably get your ass back i know they
they got like the [ __ ] you know the
pow hats on these are all like old
timers yeah and i'm there like they got
like the white hat with the string on it
yeah yeah yes sir no sir yeah and i'm
like it's enough i still still smell
like jaeger bombs and [ __ ] i'm like yeah
it's an o5 like shut up be the [ __ ]
yeah
beat it tubby your mom's waiting for you
hey [ __ ] up mister that was a tough luck
um all right let's see
bring it home
get a winner
make it a winner come on
all right this one's from nick ever go
for a drive in the car just so you could
cool off in the ac
i wouldn't say i've done that but now
currently
getting out of the shower
getting to come to the studio get out of
the shower
get ready i'm sweating and that sound
the only salvation brutal is the car
the ace however far away it is the air
conditioner in my car right now
will give you arthritis on your fingers
if you were exposed to the vents for
more than 15 minutes yeah it'll make
your fingers hurt on the wheel
it
blasts i don't know if they've they've
stepped up their game because the last
my last
foray in uh automotive air conditioner
was the 2005 mercury montego and that
stopped working about two two years ago
sure
but you used to have to put it on it
would blow hot for a little while my car
now this kia forte there's twenty one
twenty twenty
dude i mean i'm not even out of the
parking spot yet and that thing's
blowing cold air cold cold unbelievable
it's like they got dry ice in the hood i
don't know what's happening there's
nothing that drives me
crazier
than
mild air conditioning oh it's like what
are we doing put the windows something
whiskey dick air conditioning is the
worst thing ever
a lot of uber's got that because you're
in the back and they got the plastic up
and you're going buddy let's [ __ ] go
damn schvitzen over here dying yeah give
me a break will you no good gang holy
[ __ ] gang there's been a family episode
it was a fun one it was a wacky one that
was a good time baby good times we love
you uh
what do you got for him uh
follow me on all social media cameron
comedy uh you know as always rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube patreon.com bonus content
live shows baby really [ __ ] loving
live shows it's [ __ ] so cool to meet
everybody thank you all for the support
even if you watch if you listen if you
share if you're on the patreon if you do
anything
for us or watch the even if you enjoy
the show it [ __ ] means the world to
us honestly yes it does so much we love
you guys and we'll see you next week
[Music]